my vote is an act of conviction we've
come to different conclusions fellow
senators but I trust we have all
followed the dictates of our conscience
I acknowledge that my verdict will not
remove the president from office the
results of this Senate Court will in
fact be appealed to a higher court the
judgment of the American people voters
will make the final decision
just as the president's lawyers have
implored my vote will likely be in the
minority in the Senate but irrespective
of these things with my vote I will tell
my children and their children that I
did my duty to the best of my ability
believing that my country expected it of
me I will only be one name among many no
more no less
to future generations of Americans who
look at the record of this trial they
will note merely that I was among the
Senators who determined that what the
President did was wrong grievously wrong
we are all footnotes at best in the
annals of history but in the most
powerful nation on earth the nation
conceived in Liberty and justice that
distinction is enough for any citizen
Thank You mr. president I yield the
floor